there is one aspect of productivity that
I think is valuable to obsess over and
that is kind of journaling prompts and
just ask asking yourself serious
questions about why you're doing the
thing that you think you want to do
where you're actually trying to go I
spend a lot of time comparatively like
thinking is the direction I'm currently
going in actually the direction that I
want to be going in sure and I find that
there's almost no amount of too much
journaling that can that can happen
there because you know in like an hour
of journaling I might land on one
Insight which is which would if if it
nudges my course even like 0.1% that
compounds over the long term well yeah I
would say being intentional about what
you're doing and then clear with
yourself about why and what you are
doing
is really
important